hi everyone uh I'm here to talk about
deer 1.1 but really I'm actually here to
talk about reducing friction in the
latest version of the deer release uh
and by friction I really just mean
anything that kind of takes you out of
that flow state of just writing code
we've actually reduced friction in three
different ways in this release one in
case win one in some big changes to
grouping and then some really cool
things with joins so we're going to jump
right in with a kind of an easy win that
we had with case win so my wife actually
is a big tidy verse user uh this is
really cool for me because it means I
get a lot of like one-on-one feedback
about exactly what's going
wrong uh and and she writes a lot of
casewin statements that look like this
and what's going wrong is this if you
haven't seen this before casewin is
fairly strict about the types of the
things on the right hand side so she
would mix like a character like large
and small with na as a logical na here
uh and it would complain it would say no
you have to use this very special na
character thing instead if you use
casewin a lot you've probably seen this
and this isn't something we typically
expect people to know it makes case win
harder to use and harder to teach uh so
as of 1.1 a very easy win is that case
win is now much less strict about the
things on the right hand side so this
just
works
[Applause]
all right let's move on and talk about
grouping uh so I think this section is
really cool uh I play a lot of Mario
Kart uh so I came up with a question of
you know which character Mario or Luigi
or so on had the most wins on a single
track so if you had this imaginary
racist data set I'm looking for just one
row back here I want the character with
the on a track with the most number of
wins the way you might get here is say
well I'm going to group by by character
and track I'm going to compute the total
number of wins and then I'm going to
slice out the top win row if you had
actually run this code though there's a
bug in
here I only wanted Luigi at Mumu Farm
yes that is real track uh with 305 wins
that's the only one one I wanted back
but I got multiple rows I actually end
up with one per character here and the
reason this happens is that summarize by
default
just peels off one layer of grouping so
when we go into that slice Max call
we're actually still grouped by
character so we end up with one row per
character now if you're a keen deeper
user you know what the problem
is I forgot to
ungroup and I'm probably not the only
one who's forgotten to
ungroup all of you have forgotten to
ungroup remembering for the 648 time
that if deer does something weird it is
always because you have forgotten to
ungroup it has become such a thing that
people just made it a habit of group by
do the thing ungroup and every time they
call something in
deeper it has even become such a thing
that it has joined Alice and horse to
artwork where she is begging you not to
forget to invite ungrouped to the
party all right so we took a step back
and we said is there anything we could
do about this to make it so you never
have to remember to ungroup ever again
we've actually taken a page out of the
data table Playbook and as of 1.1 you
can now write the grouping in line with
the summarize
call this is pretty cool because races
goes into summarize as an ungrouped data
frame and it comes out of summarize as
an ungrouped data frame full stop no
strange uh edge cases whatsoever this
means that summarize now no longer has
to message you about what it's doing
with the grouping and you never have to
worry about that do groups argument if
you don't want to now Group by is not
going away there's no need to worry but
we think this new syntax is pretty cool
all of the major deer verbs support
it lastly I just want to talk very
quickly about joins I don't have much
time here but there is a lot here we've
introduced rolling joins inequality
joins overlap joins these new arguments
that help you with quality control like
one to one or one to many um and the
most I can do is just show you some
questions and say look these are things
that were really hard to answer with
glier before but we've reduced that
friction to essentially make them on
liners now if you ever work with time
series or you ever work with Gen genomic
data these are things that you can do
now and I think you should really look
at Hadley's art for data science book
He's written a great new section on
joins where we've introduced this new
join by helper that can let you express
very complex joins very
easily so to recap we've talked about
these three things there is a lot more
in the 1.1 release that I didn't even
get to touch but we have written a whole
series of 1.1 blog posts so I encourage
you to go to tid.org and check those out
thank you so
[Applause]
much